Germany has seen a spate of attacks on
refugee shelters this year from fire
bombings to personal assaults more than
140 since January Daniel Molitor is on
the other side he's a trained chef who
currently runs a home for refugees in
tasting it opened just three weeks ago
but there have been ultra right-wing
protestors outside every day since then
Danielle Molitor has to protect the
refugees from the haters
it's okay can I look at the fridge yeah
the facility supervisor inspects the
rules once a week full goodness goods
good good and what's of this year the
nation's finish no I'm hungry yeah but
have attention here when when it's here
but it's hot here yeah don't put it on
them it's not hot it's a girl's coat
school who okay no speaker no no German
ya okay I'm not a rubbish we have the
same problem on why the y ba ba 46
zippin 09 sin ok 30 men will live here
stay hail from Afghanistan Pakistan
Syria and India Daniel Molitor wants
them to feel at home
he provides support where he can helping
them to settle in and find their
bearings in completely new surroundings
in da one Bhishma has galleries Mars
it's a job I'm happy to do oh but gunson
Hudson I'm totally committed it has
mawkish boss Misch it's something I
enjoy and something I want to keep on
doing British isn't of course I could do
without all the pressure and aggression
on threats automatic gun yes for missing
this version but it's there I'll be ever
miss is a dog ever since the first
refugees moved into the former hotel
German men have been gathering outside
almost every day they include leading
figures from the local neo-nazi scene
Daniel monitor records their activities
on camera he considers them intimidation
tactics there have been a series of
threats against the home and against
Molitor personally that's why he should
not hide I've had two so far saying I
deserve to be strung up from a tree in
hand and that they'll get me some day um
that's among all one locally it's all
blind hatred the full of rage and
violence was mostly likely much like
lions have been unique maybe ever I
always try to tell people that even if
I'm gone someone else will take my place
and do the same job someone with courage
and passion to keep everything moving
forward yep once a prime for hunt
something and there have been threats on
social media as well this post warns
don't be surprised if one day you're put
into a dark car and never seen again an
officer from a police task force set up
to counter right wing extremists has
come by today because of the repeated
threats he takes a confidential
statement from Daniel Molitor
the local authorities have resorted to
hiring a private security company to
protect the home and its residents the
building has already been targeted with
stones bottles and stink bombs the
damage six broken windows so far with a
view tribe the broken windows are over
there you can see where they got through
we put up a board next to the fence it
doesn't provide much protection but at
least we can hear them coming in what
kind of people are they it's all kind of
people oscillators and we suspect
they're locals and I'm one lucky a
polite as opposed to get frustrated
locals more maybe they can't express
themselves in words so they showed their
dissatisfaction in another way they're
just trying to get their message across
Donyell Molitor has an appointment in
downtown Drayton he's here to meet the
organizers of a new group who are
offering to support him and the refugees
around 30 volunteers have gathered on
the grounds of a church they're planning
a welcome event at the refugee home this
coming weekend they are from India plays
oh yeah we can distribute flyers to
homes along the podemos house and invite
people perhaps mr. monitor could put up
a notice about the event it says
everyone's welcome that's esophagus
Charla um do the aina for this event on
Saturday cannot be made public fountain
does prob leave us right now we still
love neo-nazis outside the home every
day on vandy Natalia Schmidt if they
find out there's going to be a welcome
party they'll be the first to turn off
and I don't think they'll be there for
the cam startled admit by own citizen
when you plop initially kuku Mathur mine
food for thought for the volunteers who
now discuss how to keep the event secure
but they're determined not to be
intimidated no
by definition it doesn't pop unikitty
and their stock there are a small number
they're loud and they draw attention to
themselves in mood loud noise on I was
kicked a few dimensioni but there are
lots of other people who aren't as loud
and they represent the real dresden
catechesis indeed that's assembly they
contribute to communal life all over the
city and we don't want to let a few
idiots ruin that soon pavina did you
think of my lesson
the volunteers know however that a lot
of local residents tacit Lee support the
right-wing radicals and do not want the
refugees in their neighborhood sometimes
like this resident they come to vent
their discontent Danielle Molitor
listens to the man who wishes to remain
anonymous define chosen the LD I did
enough not to know the French and the
British still have their national pride
ours was broken because our grandfathers
lost a war and now we have to keep our
mouths shut and take in all these people
I'm sure most of them actually are
refugees from wars but we can't be the
world's good Samaritans Daniel Molitor
is weary of such comments but he has the
patience to listen to locals for him
that's the key to breaking down
xenophobia you're gonna open if we could
just take the aggression down a peg and
focus on the heart of the matter it
could make the best possible
arrangements an hour later the
troublemakers start to appear again the
man in the pink shirt is one of the
leaders Molitor calls the security
service yeah it's inspired two or three
of them now we'll see muggers button
anytime now that why Anne is bound to
pull up the guy who was harassing us
yesterday a shoot-off Goliath a few
stories up yaya Nazari is keeping a
close eye on the other side of the
street he's not afraid of the men
outside
I let German people and this air another
people is really pretty just looking
this one this one what is this the thugs
don't impress Abdullah Osmani he's seen
far more ominous threats in his native
Afghanistan the Taliban they were really
bad they were cutting their like people
next as well as they cut my two friends
name because he was serving with the US
many train plus I saw that tally was he
friendly bed I gonna kill my Italian
size kept out like Germany Germany and
the knotted guys better than Taliban
public country yo some tools oh you can
you can use this one here the next day
the refugees tidy up the garden in
preparation for the welcome party the
supervisor is conscious of avoiding
anything that local residents could
perceive as a provocation he wants to
prevent the arson attacks seen in other
nearby towns I'm phone is moister I
don't want the same things to happen
here that happened in fright I or my son
good wish to hear mine alone I want to
protect my people and protect the
neighbors what make you like I promise
that as long as I'm here nothing's going
to hell sign Veda does dustin ish [ __ ]
then he deals with another complaint
this woman says the refugees have been
sitting on a fragile flat roof yeah does
this is probably doc public aid kaput he
appreciates her concerns monitors
peaceful approach seems to have
alleviated her fears her blush daman
damoh so I'm pleasantly surprised All
Things Considered and they seemed decent
and consider it an attending
and mum for clicks foolishly a hammer we
can understand refugees from wars fought
about the people coming from Eastern
Europe where there's no war Russa is
here it's up to them to make things
better in their own country yeah lamb
tail off bone yeah it's kenny i can't
just leave delenn love what are we
supposed to do with these masses of
people will remember them dance mention
math in your head
it's five o'clock and the party is about
to get underway with security at the
door it's the first time the volunteers
will meet the refugees
I'm 80 and he's 18 that much we figured
out so then the host says a few words
that's been a slice Gordon even come
it's about the house in Charlotte when I
look outside this would normally be the
time when our protesters arrived but
there's nobody there so at least that's
a first little victory let's keep up the
good work thank you keeping up the good
work for a good cause and resisting the
haters even if everyone is aware that
the thugs might be back outside tomorrow